始め今のバイク乗ってるの車買ってから全然撮らなくなったんですけども最近ちょっと
母が考えていますじゃあ今日のドクターズ実刑するんですけどもこれ知ってる人いるか
な
めざ草カラフルに海の生き物のフィギュアみたいな感じで置いてあるんだが
これただのフィギュアじゃない
宇宙からなんか i こういう感じでたたの海の生き物のフィギュアみたいに見えるん
だがこれ
水に入れてしばらく放置するとめちゃくちゃ大きくなるんですよ
うわ何これ
なにこれどう見ても海の生き物剤の入ってるけどね風ミスだねこれ言葉の滝1回朝な
ことあるんですけども結構待つんですよ1週間とか結構松と神田に大きくなるんですよ
どういう原理なんでしょうもうすごい水を吸収するかなぁわかんないんですけど本当に
ビックリ数が大きくなるので今回だけだぞにこれを申したい方は明確この技けっこう
すごいと思う
ずっとこんなちっちゃいのがはなかった大きくなるんですよ子供の頃結構来る楽しんで
て今まで私は財力だったら聖子帰っちゃうだけで戦後でもまぁ大体こんなもんじゃない
ですかこんなもんなんですけどこの選考の水に入れて大きくなるうえな物体お風呂に
打ち込んでしばらく放置するとどれぐらい大きくなるのか狡猾があると元が何か今
ぐらいでもめっちゃ大きくなっ気がするんですよ
me
まったく未知です正直どれぐらい待てないかもよくありませんただ一つあることは
間違いが大きくなるという理由 that go 本に惚れ込んだよねっ
花王
[音楽]
いいいいよねぇ
i 時でも浴槽に水をためてあるんで早速レイド物体は1000個打ち込んでいき
ましょう
オスどんどん入れていくぞいきます wii
[音楽]
はいというわけでいかがでしょうなんかさーもう入れた瞬間うん若干濁ってねー水たら
すぐに god 気がするんだけどなんか濡れるセルシームーンかすげー
濁ってるんだけどこんな大きさなのがどんな香菊なるかですよね滅濁ってちゃんちゅっ
お茶をライターでちゃんと船外で終わりました日本てるねーすごいに酔ってるねーー
何かに運転
されていることが張るべきなのか育って政府を吸収するだけならも知れません書体
変わると思うんですけど渡す時を見るとかなり大きくなったような気がしますという
わけでちゃんと先行入れましたのでこの1千個がどうもう1句なるのかをさっそく見て
いきましょう
何か触れるぐらいまで来たらマジでおもろいと思うんだけど期待してるよ
t
はいえーと4日目です結構大きくなってきました
このタイミングでカンちゃんから電話ですでマーチ快適な20頭がまた経過せました
なんか結構やばいなもう水やり多くなっている気がしますね結構出てきました
さあこれ以上大きくなるんでしょうか1個いくをかなりわかりやすくなってきてました
じゃあ
もうちょいはいそういう意味でまたかなり待って抹茶までもうさえっ
これといえばこれ是非御苦労が飛び誰がやってきました
まだまだ伸びしろがありそうなんですけどもうちょっと待ってみようと思います
はい回転がまた24時間経過しましたねちょっとはみ出てくるのが多くなったぐらい
ですね
ずはいというわけでさらに24時間経過しました
どうですかねなんか陸に上がってるのがまた増えた気がしますね
多くのさ
これ上まだ大きくなりそうな可能性が
な気がしますもうちょっと待ってみましょうはいまたに舌がんたちました
どうですかねもう変化してるかどうかわかんないぐらい
おかしいでほとんどもうなんか水面出てきちゃってるんですよね
はい時で10日目です
ちょっと変化がわかりづらくなってきましたねやっぱりちょっと飛び出てくるのは
ちょっと出て植えてきてる気がしまーす
はい11日目ですもうなぁで変化しているかどうかは分かりませんこの後どうなって
いくんでしょうか
さすがにも変化があっても浮いてる浮いてるのがいる
モード月下1っぽい気がするけどもうちょっと待ってみます
うん
出息した後半まずで失速した07最初の1周学内の巨大化終わってたっぽいですねまあ
でも一応何が起こるか分からないで1か月頑張ってみたんですけどもまぁ1週間でも
かなり大きくなりましたよ対処との比較見てみてくださいもう結構も推命術ているまで
全部膨らんだんですけれども
俺の理想もっとこう年間分を者触れるぐらいに見えちゃったんでちょっと残念なんです
けどもうちょっと
うわぁ
ああああああああ
あーあえが酔拳高くなってるんだけどやばいうわぁ
すごいやってようわぁそのもともとの大きさとの比較してみましょうかこれが元々の
サイズです結構で大きくなりましたねー
もともとのサイズ今何に対しても全然大きくなってますねすごいどうせたら前回陸に
上げてみようか
[音楽]
th
最前部でました
んキモいんだよ
[音楽]
ん今日はー
でもブルークールなんですよ一つ
操作もの中1か月放置した水ってなっちゃいますよね
ああああああ
ua 救助
嘘
ua
ううううあれ
ね分議論でちゃった
あっはぁ
[音楽]
blr